today on the matt wall show a massive
spike in homicides all across the
country isn't getting the media
attention it deserves we'll look at the
numbers and talk about why this might be
happening also five headlines including
joe biden continuing his spree of
executive orders his latest order seeks
to end racism will it work and in our
daily cancellation we'll track the
evolution and masking guidance from
don't wear a mask to wear three masks
we've come a long way uh all of that and
much more today on the matt wells show
[Music]
[Applause]
perhaps you've heard that um there's an
epidemic sweeping through our country
affecting especially the most populated
areas thousands have died as a result in
the last year the worst epidemic of its
kind in american history and i'm
referring of course to
the homicide epidemic you've heard
plenty about the other epidemic but
probably not nearly as much
or maybe at all about this one
yet it seems to me to be a rather i
don't know rather a big deal
if more americans are killing each other
than ever before
that would seem like the kind of thing
we should pay attention to and talk
about
try to diagnose
indeed it would see you know i i would
say that this epidemic is
in some ways more troubling than a viral
epidemic because
um the you might say disease causing it
infects us at a much deeper level it's
not found in the respiratory tract but
in our nature in our soul
this makes it all the more newsworthy i
would think um still not a whole lot of
attention has been paid to this report
in the wall street journal from heather
mcdonald headline is taking stock of a
most violent year mcdonald writes in
part the year 2020 likely saw the
largest percentage increase in homicides
in american history murder was up nearly
37 in a sample of 57 large and
medium-sized cities based on preliminary
estimates at least 2 000 more americans
most of them black were killed in 2020
than in 2019. that's what the article
says now this is an op-ed and mcdonald
gives her opinion on what's causing this
which we'll talk about in a moment but
the information the stats as they're
reported are accurate and there have
been articles in other mainstream
outlets reporting on the rise
they really have no choice but to at
least acknowledge it but the problem has
has not gotten anything like the
attention it deserves
here's um a little bit more information
the christian science monitor this is
from an article back in december they
say to be sure overall crime has dropped
dramatically in the u.s since the late
1990s but the 2020 homicide rate now
exceeds the rates of the late 80s and
90s before the big drop says richard
rosenfeld
lead author of pandemic social unrest
and crime in u.s cities a new report
says this round of crime increases
unprecedented this year 51 cities of
various uh sizes across the us saw an
average 37 35 jump in murder from 2019
to 2020 a historically awful development
he says a different study looking at 21
u.s cities found
610 more murders in those jurisdictions
this year over last year and those
cities gun assaults also increased by 10
over 2019.
now this as i say is an extremely big
deal why is it happening well the media
seems to want to blame the pandemic
because that's i guess the safest place
to point the finger
and they're probably right at least to
an extent
um this
is something in fact that critics of the
lockdown policies warned about early on
if you attempt to shut down society all
at once take away millions of people's
jobs take millions of kids out of school
and try to bring our whole civilization
to a halt there's going to be enormous
prices to pay
some of us said that the result of this
policy this panic really would be unrest
rioting chaos violence murder poverty
unemployment on a scale unknown to
modern america
and then what happened well exactly that
we had unrest writing chaos violence
murder poverty unemployment all at
record levels
this result is horrifying though not at
all shocking to anyone who understands
human nature you simply cannot tell
330 million people to stay in their
homes for a year
maybe in some maybe in some sort of
ideal fantasy world
pandemics can be dealt with that way
people are getting sick you just say oh
everyone just stay home until it stops
maybe in an ideal world a plan like that
is something you'd think about but we
don't live in that world we live in the
actual world and when you're making
policies in the actual world you have to
account for things like human nature
this is the problem with almost every
policy advocated by people on the left
they don't understand human nature or
acknowledge it or account for it
they they imagine how they think a
policy should work
and then they implement it with little
regard for how it will work in reality
all of that to say the critics of the
lockdowns
were 100
correct
in every way across the board
i don't think we've ever seen dire
predictions pan out so perfectly so
quickly or so terribly
now does this mean that the critics of
the lockdowns are given credit for being
right
are those who called us anti-science
accusing us of trying to kill their
grandmothers are they lining up to
apologize and say hey you know you guys
were right about everything
well of course not
somehow we're still anti-science even as
our point is proven correct
speaking of proving points there is uh
there's more lying behind this homicide
epidemic than the catastrophic policies
ostensibly put in place to fight a viral
epidemic we've also seen this year and
in recent years leading up to it a surge
of anti-police sentiments and policies
making it harder if not impossible in
some cases for cops to do their jobs
surprisingly
vox in their article on the homicide
spike they actually acknowledge this as
a potential cause
though of course they they try to put
the blame
back on the police they blame the police
for being the ones to pull back
but it's good that they acknowledge it
at least here's what they say in
response to the 2014-2015 waves of black
lives matter protests against police
brutality officers in some cities pulled
back either out of fear that any act of
aggressive policing would get them in
trouble
or in a counter-protest against blm
while protesters have challenged the
crime-fighting effectiveness of police
there is a sizable body of evidence that
more and certain kinds of policing do
lead to less crime imagine that
given that some experts said that
de-policing in response to protests
could have led to more violence what
some in years past called the ferguson
effect after the 2014 protest in
ferguson missouri over the police
shooting michael brown and also seen in
baltimore after the 2015 killing of
freddie gray now it's good at least that
they admit that there's a connection
right between deep police and increased
crime
which means defund the police if we do
that on a nationwide scale eventually
we're going to be looking back on 2020
wistfully as a as a peaceful time a near
utopic time
uh when really we had the homicide
problem under control by comparison
but you can't blame you can't you can't
blame the police for being the ones to
pull back because number one oftentimes
there these are these are policies
forcing them
they're being forced to by the higher
ups by the the people who are running
who are always democrats by the way who
are running these cities
and on top of that
if you're a police officer
and you know
that if your life is in jeopardy and you
have to make a choice to save your life
you can go to jail for the rest of your
life for doing it
yeah i think that is going very
reasonably it's going to make you pull
back a little bit
cops are in a position now where you
know there of course it's all it's all
on a racial basis
if they're dealing with a white suspect
then this this pressure isn't there
because the media doesn't care when
white suspects die even if they die
unjustly
but if you're dealing with a black
suspect uh especially if you're a white
cop although even if you're not really
and you get to a point where you feel
like he's trying to possibly kill you
it's an ultimate lose-lose situation no
matter what you do in response you lose
it
at that point
um if you're in
the situation like that the cops were in
atlanta with rayshard brooks
for example stole the taser was using it
against them you're a position now you
lose whatever you do you lose
you don't fight back you can be killed
you do fight back you go to jail yeah
that's going to have an effect
what this all adds up to is a perfect
storm
right lock everyone down
take away jobs
take away school
take away police
villainize the police
while you're at it romanticize rioting
excuse violent crime as nothing but
hungry people trying to get bred
uh in aoc's words
and with all that together you're going
to get
exactly what we got
some of us saw it coming and said so
many others saw it coming and did not
say so because they were afraid and
still many more were too deluded by
their ideology to see anything at all
so looking back on this
and looking forward
to what could be ahead those of us in
the first group who saw it coming and
said so
we take no pleasure in saying
we told you so
but
we did
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
quick uh quick little fitness tip for
you a little bit fitness inspiration i
like to inspire you i don't know if you
knew this on the show i consider myself
a motivational inspirational speaker in
many ways so yesterday i was coming home
from the gym
uh stopped at the gym on the way from
home from work and um you know i've been
going to the gym
pretty regularly feeling good about that
but the problem is that my diet isn't
great i just i eat crap all the time
just a lot of junk food that's that's
the truth
and they say you can't outrun a bad diet
you know you can't work out enough to
compensate for the bad diet you're
always going to be like a net it's
always going to be a net negative
um in the end so on my way home i was
thinking about this and realizing if i
only had a good diet
i'd be doing well if it was just for the
diet part and i resolved in that moment
i had this like moment in the car
driving home and i resolved i said i'm
going to start eating healthy
from this moment on
it's going to happen
not eating junk food i'm not gonna i'm
gonna whatever you're gonna cut back on
carbs
all that stuff
and i was resolved to do it i felt i
just was i felt so motivated
and then i walked in my home
and the first thing my wife said to me
was hey we made brownies
and so i ate half the pan
immediately
and that's when i realized i had a
second epiphany
and i realized as i was eating my third
brownie
i realize you know you can't outrun a
bad diet that's true but you can go for
the tie
and uh you know that's bad that i think
that's good enough right
just kind of maintaining where you're at
that's what i'm going for
all right number one joe biden um
continued signing executive orders
yesterday he signed i think what is it i
think he's up to 5 000 executive orders
so far
just he wakes up in the morning and
whatever thought he happens to think
that day he'll convert it into a
executive order i think he'll be signing
an executive order today to declare that
chipmunks are the cutest forest animals
anything at all any thought he happens
to think let's make it into an executive
order uh but remember of course trump
was the the dictator of the fascist um
biden will beat
trump's executive order total in like a
few months
that's that's that's the rate he's on
now
um and so on that end
yesterday he signed he signed a racial
equity executive order
and of course he tied it to george floyd
here he is explaining why he's signing
the order
but when many americans didn't see or
had simply refused to see
couldn't be ignored any longer
those
eight minutes and 46 seconds
that took george floyd's life
opened the eyes of millions of americans
and millions of people around all over
the world
it was the knee on the neck of justice
and it wouldn't be forgotten
it stirred the conscious and of tens of
millions of americans
and in my view it marked a turning point
in this country's attitude toward racial
justice
yeah eye-opening moment you know i
thought it was pretty eye-opening when
we got the toxicology report back and uh
we were told that he had lethal
levels of fentanyl in a system i thought
that was pretty eye opening too
um that that that to me was pretty
enlightening
as well
now joe biden also uh we talked last
week about the 1776 commission
that president trump formed and they
released their report which we went
through a little bit of it
uh worth reading except that you can't
read it because one of the first things
that biden did when he took office he
deleted it he took it down
and now he announced part of this part
of this racial equity plan is to do away
with the 1776 commission he is
explaining that
look in the weeks ahead
i'll be
reaffirming the federal government's
commitment to diversity equity and
inclusion and accessibility building on
the work we started in the obama biden
administration
that's why
i rescinded the previous
administration's harmful ban on
diversity and sensitivity training and
abolish the offensive counter factual
1776 commission
unity and healing
must begin with understanding and truth
not ignorance and lies
today i'm also issuing an executive
order and that will ultimately end the
justice department's use of private
prisons private prisons
an industry that houses pre-child
detrainees and detainees and federal
prisoners
the executive order directs the attorney
general to decline to renew contracts
with privately operated criminal
facilities
a step we started to take at the end of
the obama administration
and was reversed under the previous
administration
yeah so he talks about there abolishing
the uh the 1776 commission
you know and he also says he also says
it's it's count counterfactual is the
17th what part of it is counterfactual
the the report
lays out basic facts of american history
and as soon as it was released we were
told by the media and the left that oh
it's an assault on truth and on this is
not history at all what part of it isn't
history
you know they they never explained that
did they
they never told us exactly what part of
it is false
of course the the only part they really
the the primary part they disagree with
is just the
point that the 1776 commission made
which is that slavery
an awful evil thing nobody didn't
literally nobody at least nobody in the
west denies it
some parts of the world where they still
have slavery maybe they do deny it but
certainly in the west nobody denies that
but it's also not a crime or a sin
unique to western society the white man
didn't invent slavery
that does matter
you know that matters because when we're
going back and we're looking at our um
the heroes of our history
we have to understand them within
context
and if there's a certain evil thing that
someone in history
uh
took part in
or
at least did not object to and then you
and then you and then you take and then
you take a step back and you take a
wider view of it and you see that pretty
much everyone in history up until that
point also was not objecting to it
then yeah that that matters not i don't
know how many times i have to explain
this that matters not in judging the
objective um morality of the act itself
now we know that slavery is a horrible
evil always has been always will be
and you can make statements like that
when you believe in objective morality
the the irony here is that the left
they're moral relativists so they have
even less standing to judge anyone 200
200 years ago who practiced slavery or
believed in it
because according to them morality is
relative and 200 years ago 250 years ago
300 years ago all throughout history
the the relative morality of that time
was that slavery was okay now if you're
a moral relativist you have no basis
upon which to criticize that
now if you believe in objective morality
as i do then i can say 250 years ago if
you practice slavery or or
or even failed to protest against it
then that is an evil act
but when judging the moral culpability
of any individual who engaged in it
that's when you have to take into
account context
the context of the time
um
and that's the difference
but again as a moral relativist
that is just the the incredible irony
here it's the moral relativists
who are the ones going back through
history
and holding
you know
our historical figures to the standards
of today
i think that's stupid to do on any
philosophical grounds you especially
can't do it as a relativist makes no
sense
all right one other clip i want to play
because because
biden has one other thing to say here
that i thought was was was interesting
but not for the reason he intended let's
take a listen we've never fully lived up
to the founding principles of this
nation state the obvious
that all people are created equal and
have a right to be treated equally
throughout their lives
and it's time to act now not only
because it's the right thing to do but
because if we do
we'll all be better off for it
for too long we've allowed a narrow
cramped view of the promise of this
nation to fester
you know we've uh we've bought the view
that america is a zero-sum game in many
cases
if you succeed i fail
if you get ahead i fall behind
if you get the job i lose mine
maybe worst of all
if i hold you down i lift myself up
yeah i actually agree with him there i
agree with with what he just said um
but i don't think he understands what
he's saying and i think that's a problem
that's still gonna get worse as time
goes on but he's saying we've bought
this incorrect view that america is a is
a zero-sum game and you know if i
succeed it means you fail
you're right
that is that is an incorrect view it is
a view that a lot of people have bought
into it is wrong we do need to push back
against it
but that's the view that is being
propagated by your side dude that's
that's you that's you and your side
that's what you're saying
we here over here as conservatives we've
been we have been the ones saying what
you just said that's not the way it
works
that's why you don't have to look with
resentment on someone who's wealthy and
successful just because someone's
wealthy and successful it doesn't mean
they're taking something away from you
you don't have to take from from someone
in order for other people to be
successful if you want to help the less
successful be more successful doesn't
mean you have to take away from the ones
who are successful because because it's
not a zero-sum game that is an incorrect
view
but again biden it's your
view not ours
all right number two i wanted to read
this to you um just as a really perfect
example of fake news i saw someone
someone shared this is this from a it's
from a recent article in washington post
actually from a couple weeks ago but um
i saw this being shared so it's an
article in washington post about
um
about biden's transgender policies right
and listen this is one paragraph in the
article listen listen to the framing of
this paragraph
transgender rights have become a
lightning rod in the relentless culture
war that has come to dominate american
politics
pitting conservative christians who want
their religious views to be accommodated
against liberal and secular americans
who think some of those views trample on
minority groups as rights
you see that see this is fake news
this is how fake news works
it is it is not usually a matter of
inventing a story out of whole cloth and
sometimes fake news does that too
most of the time though and it's the
most insidious and damaging form it's
this
it is in taking something and framing it
in a certain way
and so the framing here
they say conservative christians who
want their religious views to be
accommodated so now look what they've
done here
uh it's it's almost brilliant um
they've taken an issue
of a small minority of biological men
who want access to female locker rooms
but now
if you object to that
and you simply want things to continue
as they always have been
forever which is that you've got men and
women in locker rooms and bathrooms and
we just stick with that
then now you are the one asking to be
accommodated it's not the handful the
smattering of biological men who want to
go into the to the women's bathroom
they're not the ones asking to be
accommodated no
you're asking to be accommodated when
you say no i don't want that
so by objecting
to the accommodations
that this minority is asking for you in
effect now are the one asking for an
accommodation
brilliant
devious
but brilliant because maybe not so
brilliant but people fall for it anyway
i don't know if the framing is brilliant
or people are just stupid or if it's one
of the other but it works
number three from the blaze a woman who
criticized white privilege on social
media was charged with the child abuse
murder of her three-year-old foster
child who was white
the disturbing story unfolded in
simpsonville south carolina police
allege that arielle robinson 29 and her
husband jerry robinson 34 and inflicted
a series of blunt force injuries on
their adopted child
victoria rose smith
the parents called 911 on january 15th
to report that the child was
unresponsive when medical professionals
arrived they immediately suspected child
abuse according to the heavily redacted
police report
um
the and and i read the police report by
the way we talked about it's
heavily redacted as an understatement
almost every single word is blocked out
except for a few
so there's a whole lot in that police
report that they don't want the public
to see
why is that well we don't know that's
why it's redacted but it does raise
certainly a lot of questions
uh as ariel robinson she was also
on a food network show called worst
cooks in america
and she won that show apparently
um
but
the most relevant fact
about her about her background anyway
possibly
is um
that she
would frequently post on social media
decrying things like white privilege
so she posted very recently this was on
january 6th
the murder happened on
january 11th i believe so less than a
week
before she says in my house my black
children get treated the same as my
white children and my white children get
treated the same as my black children
it's a shame that when they go out into
the real world
that won't be the case
adding hashtags for white privilege and
black lives matter
so this is a black woman
who
complained about white privilege
and you know advocated for black lives
matter
shortly before
allegedly beating her white adoptive
daughter to death
i i it goes without saying now at this
point but i'm going to say it anyway
because all i do is point out the
obvious anymore but someone has to do it
reverse the races on this story
and this is headline news everywhere
i mean can you imagine
a case where
a white
adoptive mother of a
black child
let's say criticized blm
and shortly after that beat her black
child to death
if that were to happen that would be
news everywhere headline news everywhere
and we'd be linking it to systemic
racism and all this kind of stuff
this happens and not a lot of attention
at all
the story only gets worse um
because you start asking a question you
know
how did this woman
manage to adopt a child like how how
could they not i know you can't read
someone's mind and there's only so much
you can do when someone's coming in to
adopt a child there's only so much you
can do to screen out the the the
psychopaths but
did they could they really not tell
if she is indeed guilty of doing this
the kind of woman would beat a child to
death you you you can't tell that
there were no red flags
it's harder to believe that there are no
red flags when you consider we'll play
this video for you this um
this was i think first found by tmz and
they posted it online this is from a
couple years ago i believe here is ariel
robinson performing a quote-unquote
stand-up act
where she jokes about
abusing her children and locking them in
a cage listen
so we're trying to adopt a baby girl and
the social worker you know they have to
come over and you know see that you're
not too crazy to adopt
the hallway she's coming over i'm
thinking i'm telling my husband i said
you know what we should have locked the
other two up in cages because
she meet them two ain't no way they
don't give us a note
she gets theirs too late they upstairs
hollering screaming when mom's asking
where am i
okay
i don't like your kids either
so they understand how screaming going
on you know you get to that mommy level
and you like you haven't had so i forget
this moment is in my face so i turn
around yeah upstairs shut up come on and
punch you in your throat
turn back around and she's looking at me
[Laughter]
hey listen to those cackling hyenas in
the audience
isn't that hilarious she's talking about
abusing her children
and according to that story i don't know
it might have been a little hard to hear
what you were saying because of the
audio quality there but according to the
story that she tells in this
quote-unquote comedy act she says that
she threatened to punch her children in
the throat
screamed it at them in front of an
official from the adoption agency now
did she make this story up we don't know
but either way here she out she is in
public joking about abusing her children
so she's the kind of woman who publicly
jokes about abusing her children
and then allegedly actually beat her
child to death
um shortly after adopting the girl
she was adopted a year or two earlier
um
and there were no red flags at all
you couldn't see that anything was amiss
really
there are a lot of questions here there
are a lot of questions we should be
asking
was this a racially motivated hate crime
against against her own adopted daughter
that's a fair question and again if you
reverse the races it will be a question
everyone would ask and so i'm going to
ask that question we deserve to know
why did they redact the police report so
heavily
was there an indication of that i don't
know
and how is it that a woman and you take
the race out of it how is it that a
woman like that
was able to adopt a child
i mean serious accountability but the
problem is there needs to be
accountability that probably won't be
because the media is not going to touch
the story with the 10-foot pole at least
they're not going to touch the racial
aspects of it certainly
and you know this that story she told
did that actually happen
where there was a some sort of official
there and witnessed that
because if it did then that official who
witnessed it should go to jail too
and as far as this woman if she's guilty
this is why
i'm at a point now where you you
couldn't possibly even though in the
past i've been against the death penalty
i'm at a point now because of things
like this you couldn't possibly convince
me to go back
to those days um this is what we need
the death penalty for our people like
this
you beat a child to death we just we
don't need you on earth um we don't need
you on earth we need you gone from the
earth as as quickly as possible
all right number five um actually i
think it's number four but i'm skipping
ahead i guess
uh from the hill it says
it may be a man's world in hollywood
but kiera knightley will no longer
perform sex scenes under a male director
so she's getting a lot of she's getting
a lot of credit she's getting praised
for this
while the actor has done nude and sex
scenes in the past she now has a no
nudity clause in her contract that only
someone has to do with how her body has
changed after having two children
she says it's partly vanity
but also the male gaze
so she says she doesn't want uh she's
she's not interested in the male gaze
anymore and so she said she's not going
to do nude scenes with a male director
she'll still do them so she's getting
she's getting credit for this is a great
feminist statement she'll still do them
it's just that she won't do it with a
male director because she's worried
about the male gaze
you do have to ask
what about the male gaze of the people
in the audience
what about crew members
producers
just more
more absolutely hollow um me too esque
virtue single signaling from feminists
in hollywood
what else is new
you know there there are few feelings
um more uncomfortable than when you're
stuck in a car
and you're starting to feel carsick i
had this experience in fact just this
past week i was coming home from the
airport uh i was in i was in the uber
and i just started that that wave
because i had really bad car seat
because that wave of nausea started to
started to i started starting to feel it
and it gets really intense and you don't
want to tell the uber driver to pull
over so you can vomit on the side of the
highway uh nor do you want to vomit
inside the car either because that's
generally frowned upon so you just
suffer through it and the thing is i
didn't have with me my mistake at the
time my relief ban usually i have it
with me and that's why you need to make
sure you get relief banned and always
have it with you if you're going to be
in a car or traveling if you're prone to
nausea for any other reason relief ban
is the number one fda cleared
anti-nausea wristband that's been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraine hangover morning sickness
chemotherapy and such so much more the
product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy
provides all-natural relief with zero
side effects for as long as needed they
do sell pills you know you can get that
they're supposed to deal with with
nausea from motion sickness but those
are going to make you drowsy and a lot
of times you you know you can't afford
to take something that's gonna put you
to sleep in the middle of the day relief
bend is the only over-the-counter
wearable device that's been used in
hospitals and oncology clinics to treat
nausea and vomiting so you know it works
they you know the the the people they
use in hospitals you know it's got to
work this new year ensure that nausea is
never the reason to miss out on life's
important moments right now relief ban
has an exclusive offer just for my
listeners if you go to reliefband.com
and use promo code walsh you'll receive
20 off plus free shipping and no
questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee so head to r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use our promo code walsh for
20 off
and um after you do that make sure to
head right over to thedailywire.com
dailywire.com become a daily wire member
use promo code rhf to get 25 off for
there uh that's rhf for 25 off and if
you do that you'll get access to all the
perks that you know come with being a
daily wire member but most importantly
right now you can watch our new feature
film our first feature film that we're
very excited about run hide fight uh and
we picked run height fight you know
you've heard us talking about it and you
know by now it's not a politically
correct movie it's not a kids movie it's
an intense movie
um but it's a movie the hollywood
studios didn't want any part of
uh now they might be regretting that a
little bit when they see the incredible
reception it's gotten you can go to
rotten tomatoes and see it's got a 93
audience rating with 2 000 reviews so
trust the people listen to what the
people are saying and check out this
film you can catch it over at
dailywire.com or on our mobile app or on
our streaming apps at apple tv and roku
if you're not a daily wire member yet
use promo code rhf to get 25 off that's
again rhf for 25 off now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
let us for a moment follow the science
in fact let's follow the science back
all the way back to ancient times the
days of old the days of yore
march of 2020 back then we were told
that we were anti-scientific morons if
we were a mask out in public
the surgeon general
screamed at us back in it was february
he said in all caps stop buying masks
and said explicitly that masks are quote
not effective in preventing and the
general public from catching the
chronovirus
the beloved dr fauci had a similar
message at the time this is what he said
back in march let's listen
there's a lot of confusion among people
and misinformation surrounding face
masks can you discuss that the masks are
important
for someone who's infected to prevent
them from infecting someone else now
when you see people and look at the
films in china and south korea whatever
everybody's wearing a mask
right now in the united states
people should not be walking around with
masks
you're sure of it because people are
listening really no closely to this
right now people should not be walked
there's no reason to be walking around
with a mask
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
wearing a mask might make people feel
a little bit better and it might even
block a droplet but it's not providing
the perfect protection that people think
that it is and often
there are unintended consequences people
keep fiddling with the mask and they
keep touching their face
and can you get some schmutz sort of
staying inside there of course of course
huh
but you know when one follows the
science one will be taken down a twisty
windy road
soon after these uh soon after these
public officials told us not to wear
masks
they were telling us not only that
actually we should wear masks but that
not wearing masks that is believing what
they said 12 seconds ago i suppose what
they're saying now makes us anti-science
it was anti-science to wear a mask in
march in may it was anti-science not to
wear a mask
and now we're rapidly approaching a
point where it's anti-science to only
wear one mask rather than two
here's what fauci is saying about that
today a lot of folks are hearing now
about double masking wearing two masks
or trying to get one of those n95
medical grade masks do you believe that
that's advisable and makes a difference
you know it it likely does because i
mean this is a physical covering to
prevent uh droplets and virus to get in
so if you have a physical covering with
one layer you put another layer on it
just makes common sense that it likely
would be more effective and that's the
reason why you see people either double
masking or doing a version of an n95
huh
so it was common sense that we shouldn't
wear a mask
before now it's common sense to wear two
and now we're in sort of an arms race
from no mass to one mask to mask a
pattern seems to be emerging and
the real scientific visionaries are
trying to stay one step ahead of the
game that's why a segment on cnbc this
week upped the ante even further listen
to this
the experts keep telling us that wearing
masks is really about protecting our
cell protecting others from ourselves in
the event that we are contagious but you
know if other people aren't wearing
their masks or they're wearing them
improperly we need to protect ourselves
so experts say you can double up with a
tight weave fabric mask for added
protection now virginia tech researchers
found that doubling up these cloth masks
increases the efficacy from 50 to 75
percent a three-layer mass could block
up to 90 percent of the particles
yes three masks
so from don't wear masks to wear three
masks in less than a year
now a number of questions may arise in
your mind
you may think wait a second
medical masks have been around for
centuries there isn't much we know about
masks now today that we didn't know 10
months ago
sure this particular type of coronavirus
might be novel but the basic science
behind masking is not novel
something isn't right here you might
think
you might continue by thinking it almost
seems as though the public messaging on
mass has little to do with science
and has had little to do with science in
the beginning you might think
and you might even continue to think in
addition i mean
whether masks are effective or not isn't
there very good evidence here that our
public officials were either lying to us
in march or are lying now
and when you consider that the change in
the mask recommendations happen in the
span of a month from march to april not
10 months
does that make it all the more
suspicious
again you might think
you don't have to be anti-mass to be
disturbed by this in fact if you're pro
mask and you believe what you're being
told now
then doesn't that mean that officials
like fauci are responsible for the
deaths of thousands of people for
telling people not to wear them early on
precisely when there was the best chance
for containing the virus
if fauci thought that masks were
effective and said otherwise
no matter his reason
is that not a major scandal and by the
pro-mask way of thinking perhaps one of
the most lethal lies ever told by our
government
you might think all of this
if you hate science
but those of us who are respecters of
science believers of science lovers
of science in love with science those of
us who love science so much that we're
practically romantically involved with
it we know that science means not asking
questions
there is no room for skepticism in
science
i mean do you hear the word skepticism
in science i don't
they don't call it psy psyskeptimismiss
do they it's science
science is all about dogmatically
accepting the prevailing notions of the
day
even if those notions seem to change
every 30 minutes
that is what science is all about
if you really believe in science you
will just keep putting stuff on your
face whenever you're told to do so
personally the equation that i've worked
out scientifically is that every mask
you wear
represents 10 percent love for your
fellow man okay now it's all it gets
very very complicated but follow me with
me here if you wear no mask you have no
love
one mask means you have only ten percent
love three masks makes a mere 30 percent
better than zero better than ten
not as good as it could be
that's why i wear 11 masks because i
always give 110
and this means that my love is perfect
and pure better than perfect and pure
i have 10 masks worth of love
i look with pity on you
one in two maskers
pathetic
you will never respect science the way
that i do or care for humanity the way
that i do
i even wear masks around my ears to make
sure that no virus enters or escapes
through those passageways i wear a mask
over my eyes so that no one's effect
infected when you know uh my love for
science and humanity moves me to tears
as it so often does
the only problem is that i can't see
anything and i've already been hit by
cars three times
but
this is a price worth paying
for science
for the world
for you
and so anyone who does not follow the
science and continue putting layers of
masks on until they cannot speak or
breathe
is
canceled
and we'll end it there on a little bit
of a science lesson help you learn
something
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pavel vadosky the show is edited
by danny d'amico our audio is mixed by
mike coromina hair and makeup is done by
nika geneva and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matte
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show after the media spent
four years warning of incipient
dictatorship president biden admits that
he's kind of acting like a dictator
that's today on ben shapiro show